it's easily both the most famous and
Infamous firearm in all of the world's
history with over 100 million made its
appearance in over half a center of
Cinema and its place in the hands of
players in hundreds of video games
the aftermath kalashnikova model of 1947
is undeniably the most recognizable
weapon ever made we've come here to the
Royal armories Museum in the UK to chart
the AK-47s Journey from its creation
through to its huge pop culture
footprint in the context of
entertainment it makes perfect sense to
fully Embrace that that stereotype of
the AK as rough ready but reliable and
Powerful
so why is the AK-47 such a legendary
weapon why is AK-47 used as a catch-all
term and why do so many games get this
famous firearm so wrong
[Music]
the AK-47 or kalajnikov model 1947 is a
7.62 by 39 millimeter gas operated
assault rifle developed within the
Soviet Union by t-34 tank commander and
designer Mikhail timofeyovic kalajnikov
Mikhail was wounded during the German
invasion of the USSR in 1941 during the
Battle of briansk while in hospital he
overheard fellow soldiers complaining
about their rifles and having seen
firsthand the combat Advantage the
German forces had thanks to their
Superior Firearms Kalashnikov resolved
to develop a better weapon for his
country's forces collagenikov would take
a number of weapons through prototyping
stages including early versions of this
famous rifle which won a 1946 Soviet
rifle design competition by November
1947 he had further simplified the
rifle's production and design and it was
this 47 model that would enter the 1947
and 48 Soviet Army trials impressing the
Soviet military enough that in 1949 they
would adopt the weapon into military
service it was a desirable firearm for
many reasons it was easy to operate
capable of automatic fire remained
reliable under some of the harshest
conditions and in relative terms it was
cheap and easy to mass produce its
reliability is historic as is the sheer
number of them that have found their way
around the world the AK silhouette is
Iconic with Mozambique even putting it
on their flag and you would be
hard-pressed to find someone who doesn't
know what an AK-47 is or an action movie
franchise that hasn't featured them or
especially an FPS series that hasn't
taken inspiration from them
for all of its Fame and infamy for
everything its symbolism represents and
for all the times it's graced our
screens it makes it all the more
peculiar that technically so many of us
have been misnaming it all along so if
we want to get super technical so the
Prototype that was a that was accepted
for service in 1947 was the AK-47 but
strictly speaking that was just one of
many prototypes and that's the one this
they settled upon you can call it the
AK-47 but if you're going to really it's
probably just the very first version
that were made really for only a year or
two in 1949 we shouldn't really call
anything later than that an AK-47 but
that ship has sailed the name has become
iconic as AK-47 and you we're never
going to stop people calling it AK-47
one of the key factors that led to the
ak's immense reputation was the sheer
quantity that it was produced finding
their ways into all sorts of corners of
the world is by far the most produced
firearm in history the AKA is an amazing
weapon justified in its place in history
and in contemporary use as well of
course but part of that story is just
the sheer number that were made and the
sheer number that were put out there by
the Soviet Union but then also licensed
and unlicensed production means that we
have more of these things than any other
single type or category even a firearm
out there and this is why you'll see
estimates of between 75 million and 120
million no one even knows how many of
these things are out there another
element of its popularity and why one
version or another of the AK platform is
found around the globe is that the
format was constantly being tinkered
with and iterated on the m in akm
standing for modernized is a simplified
lighter version of the AK platform that
was more optimized for mass production
and it was this version that would
become the Soviet Union service rifle
from 90 1859 and for its advantages
become the most prevalent version across
the globe a fact that remains true today
due to its success and fame the rifle
has been widely imitated with many
countries producing their own variant of
the platform the most popular of which
being the Chinese type 56. they're
similar enough that a lot of games and
movies will mismatch their names or use
AK-47 as a blanket term but if you're
ever in a game and want to know if
you're aiming down the sights of a
Soviet AK or a Chinese type 56 you can
take a look at the hooded front sight if
it's closed then it's probably a type 56
open then it's an AK
this is a minor detail that's often
overlooked in games but once you notice
these little characteristics and
clashing names you will no doubt start
seeing them in many of your favorite
Shooters but what about the AK of today
and how has its Legacy continued into
the modern day the 5.45 by 39 millimeter
cartridge of the AK-74 and ak-74m are
currently the main service rifles for
over a dozen countries but the
modernized version of kalashnikov's
model 1974 that is in use today only
ends in production in 1991 and more
recently the future main service rifle
of the Russian army the ak-12 saw its
first confirmed use in a conflict during
the 2022 invasion of Ukraine there are
of course many more variants or new
versions of the rifle that we see Pop Up
in games and movies there's the rpk
which is basically the light machine gun
parallel of the akm there's a slew of
AKs featuring a folding stock marked by
an s in their designation the further
compacted aks-74u often miscategorized
in video games as a submachine gun as
well as the ak-15 19 101 102 103 104 105
and even Beyond throughout the AK 100
and 200 series all of this is to say
that the platform and Legacy of Mikhail
Kalashnikov is still going strong with
such a vast Legacy and reputation in the
real world it's hardly surprising that
the AK-47 in all of its forms and
variants has become such a juggernaut
within pop culture its most iconic early
entry is surely in 1997's Goldeneye 007
for the Nintendo 64. where the weapon
was given its first alternate universe
title as the kf-7 Soviet a name that I
think we can agree keeps the AK-47
flavor and a design that definitely
keeps the stylings of the real deal
the early 2000s saw a lot of games
explored different conflict zones and
settings with many military Shooters
taking place in the Middle East like
conflict Desert Storm across the Vietnam
War in titles like Viet Cong or manavala
as well as featuring in games involving
cops criminals or counter-terrorists
from GTA 3 to Counter-Strike
what is interesting though
is games have diverse gameplay locations
time periods and stories yet the AK
feels at home in each and every one of
them
of course the AK is also an icon on the
Silver Screen as well with America being
at the Forefront of Cinema since the
early 20th century and given the ak's
history and use among so many that the
USA once called enemy the Russian AK has
become the quintessential bad guy gun
if I had to pick one reason why the
Kalashnikov is as iconic as it is it's
probably the Vietnam War this is where
the West like really ran into this
actually quite well established new
rifle I think I think a lot of the the
obsession with the Clash of in the west
is to do with that it's the weapon of
the enemy be that the Soviet Union the
Cold War but if you have to pick a grand
zero for its cultural popularity it's
probably that you know it crop then
crops up in all of the Vietnam War
movies stories and pictures as well of
GIS picking up the Kalashnikov in favor
of their M16 which at that time might
not be working so so well and then it
just doesn't go away from there in the
80s and 90s Soviet and Russian forces
were a common antagonist in plenty of
spy films and action movies meaning the
AK was commonplace in films like Air
Force One and the Rambo series as well
as being found in the hands of James
Bond in octopussy or GoldenEye
media can be used as propaganda either
aggressively or more subtly and with a
huge amount of that media being made by
or set in NATO countries it's not
surprising that the armaments that are
featured in those stories follow those
political lines so often we have seen
the stereotypical good guy in action
movies wielding things like AR-15s
Glocks or mp5s weapons of the West
mirrored by movie bad guys and
antagonists using Russian AKs or Chinese
type 56 rifles although perhaps one of
the most iconic AK scenes in any piece
of media or maybe just my favorite is
With Yuri orlov's fawning love letter to
the rifle it will shoot whether it's
covered in mud or filled with sand it's
so easy even a child can use it and they
do much like its depictions in Hollywood
the ak's appearance in video games have
very much followed the Firearms many
tropes pop culture will play to its
reputation of reliability and resilience
showing the AK as a weapon still going
strong after the world has ended as seen
in post-apocalyptic games like Fallout
franchise the Metro series or stalker
games have also followed the trend of
showing it as a weapon of enemy
combatants in the same settings and
backdrops that films have with many
players first encountering a weapon in
story modes and campaigns being where
they lift it from the ground after
dispatching an enemy the AK also helps
diversify the inventory of our virtual
armories both with its recognizable
silhouette aesthetic and wooden
furniture that's often odds with Western
weapon designs but also in the way it
performs where it's often portrayed with
higher stopping power and more recoil to
boot
for the most part games follow this
formula with their AKs making them do
more damage than the M4 or AR-15
Alternatives many of the Call of Duty
titles over the years have done exactly
this giving their AKs more damage but
dialing back their rate of fire to
further accentuate the slower chug of
the virtual AK-47
in games of Counter-Strike you'll often
see counter-terrorists ditching their
m4s for the enemy's cheaper AK due to
its ability to penetrate helmets and
result in a One-Shot headshot
and an escape from tarkov multiple
variants of the AK can be found across
its maps and Traders as well as in the
hands of both Ai and player scavengers
with a weapon and its ammunition being
all the more plentiful due to its
setting in a fictional Russian city
personally I think escape from tarkov
takes the trophy for the best virtual
representation of the AK platform and
not just because it features so many
different variants of the dang thing
but also for its detailed Aesthetics its
animated working parts and playing on
the resilience of the weapon by showing
it operating without a dust cover or a
muzzle break and with the thing still
firing despite whatever trash you're
throwing through the barrel although I
suppose it's not surprising that a
Russian Studio has built the best
virtual AKs
the name AK-47 is Iconic and
recognizable so it's not surprising that
many games will choose to keep the
designation regardless of if they
modeled their in-game version off of a
different variant or not a lot of games
will lean more on the Aesthetics of the
weapon because they know that the large
majority of players will glance at it
and Associate it with being an AK even
if it's GTA 5's type 56 simply named
assault rifle or even when developers
want to avoid the actual designation but
still want the weapon to feel Soviet we
get names like perfect darks kf7 special
Sniper Ghost Warrior 3's aka47
the Metro franchise's Clash rifle
or my personal favorite Kanan Lynch 2's
kaliningrad 47.
all of this shows that developers can be
pretty fluid with naming conventions and
small details but still give the player
the feeling that they're using an AK-47
as after all that's what the majority of
players will know it as and may even
refer to it by and even more interesting
is when games try to create the
connection and Aura of an AK even in
games that are set in a far future or in
different realities altogether Apex
Legends has its vk-47 Flatline its title
obviously a nod to the AK-47 with much
of its Aesthetics made to look like a
science fiction Bullpup AK or valorin's
Vandal rifle which is a punchier and
slower option of the fully automatic
rifles available to purchase obviously
its stylings are heavily influenced by
the real world AK and its performance in
game follows established tropes
Call of Duty titles still needed an 8K
for their inventories even if they're
leaning into a future setting and that
gives us the Black Ops 4 KN 57 or
infinite warfare's Volk rifle and of
course Borderlands has a whole
manufacturer that Apes the Soviet
stylings of Weaponry in vladov with a
lot of these over-the-top weapons
featuring elements from either an AK or
one of its look-alikes it goes to show
that wooden furniture utilitarian design
and a good amount of stopping power can
be especially useful on a planet like
Pandora for all of these examples of
misnaming mishmash designs or hints of
an AK just scratches the surface of what
so many virtual weapons lean into
so the AK in video gaming history it's
so iconic it's another one of those
designs that you have to get right to
some extent and it's hard to get badly
wrong if games fall down at all they
they fall down as everyone else does by
depicting the AK in caricature almost so
you have a beefier heavier recoiling
cartridge which gives you more more
damage in terms of hit points or
whatever but maybe your dispersion of
shots opens up quicker the the animation
of the model recoils more and takes more
time to settle down after a burst so you
get that Pro con thing of a more
powerful cartridge of course in reality
that 762 AK cartridge has more recoil
energy than 5.56 it's not in any way
super powerful by comparison to 5.56
they're pretty comparable I know some
people will disagree but we can't really
have that in typical video games because
we have to have differentiation we have
to have that Pro con that trade-off and
so we see in an exaggeration of how much
recoil it has how much damage it does
and in the context of entertainment it
makes perfect sense to fully Embrace
that that stereotype of the AK as rough
ready but reliable and powerful and
especially if you're setting that
against something like an M16 to
contrast it
[Music]
as games have developed the virtual
Weaponry that we play with keeps getting
more and more detailed I love that there
are games like ARMA 3 or escape from
targov that go the extra mile and ensure
every element of this iconic firearm is
modeled and showcased with as much
detail or authenticity as possible
whereas other titles like Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 2 GTA 5 or Ghost Recon
breakpoint hybridize or simplify much of
the weapon instead letting it connect
with the players through recognizable
Aesthetics and gameplay
and with it being a weapon so firmly
cemented in the minds of so many people
it may be Unthinkable to have a modern
video game shooter without some form of
the AK present on the weapon list the
Legacy that surrounds the real thing can
be used to sow story elements and build
on The Narrative of the world while the
tropes that surround the virtual version
can add much needed diversity to the
guns at the player disposal true to its
famed resilience and robustness whether
in the real world are movies or even our
video games the app to Matt collajnikova
is here to stay
thank you so much for watching this
week's episode of Loadout if you enjoyed
make sure to hit the like button
subscribe for more like this and let me
know in the comments section what you'd
like to see future episodes on or of
course you can reach out to me directly
on Twitter at a regular Dave if you want
more video game Weaponry content you can
watch the previous series of this show
or check out our weekly series of
firearms expert reacts where I show our
friends at the Royal armories a
selection of video game arms to break
down and make sure to subscribe as we'll
have a bonus video where Jonathan breaks
down the different variants of the AK on
the channel in the next couple of days
until next time I've been your host Dave
Jewett thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]